hello Steve Kaufman here I gotta be a
way for a few for a few days so I
thought I would I would talk about today
and I must admit that I'm a little bit
lazy when it comes to actually writing
out my thoughts on my blog so it's very
convenient for me to just record them
here it goes up as a podcast on as a
video cam and I look forward to to
feedback we talked a bit about crashing
I talked about about the lip but I saw
where the limits of crashing then we've
had a tremendous exchange of my blog the
linguist on language some very
thoughtful posts by people like Igor
Igor the Macedonian as I like to call
him and he likes to be called one day
I'll have to visit that country and from
John Fotheringham who is in Taiwan and
who is a very enlightened language
teacher and I think we have to stop and
pause a bit that we're living in this
internet age where I can sit down here
and talk to people via the computer and
I can refer to comments that people have
made on my space the conversations that
I'm having across time zones in to
Taiwan and and Macedonia that's the
world we're living in today and that's
important when we think about language
learning I want to refer a little later
to a reference that Igor provided which
I thought was very interesting but first
one of the reasons why I'm jumping right
back in so soon after my last video is
that it was brought to my attention that
there was an exchange at this website
and I'll post the URL at my blog called
how to learn any language any time or
something like that most of the people
who go there are language learning
Keener's and they have run a thread for
23 pages talking about whether one needs
to have formal instruction or to do
formal structure and grammar learning or
whether one can learn simply by
listening and reading and for some
people I think that listening reading is
the way to go they support the crash
you and they point to example such as
and the names were mentioned Moses
McCormick is one there's capital LOM
whose office also often mentioned myself
and of course thereupon a number of
people jumped in to criticize they
criticized Moses mcCormick they
criticized me someone said that if I had
put more effort into grammar my Russian
wouldn't be it wouldn't have so many
mistakes and so I just want to address
that initially first of all I think
Moses McCormick is a great guy I've seen
his videos if you googled for Moses
mcCormick the language or something or
look in YouTube you'll find his videos
he has the right attitude enjoy the
language just relax
communicate enjoy it for whatever
purpose you may have stooge a ray is
another guy just enjoy that there are
gonna be some languages that he speaks
better than others some languages that I
speak better than others it doesn't
matter
my purpose and learning Russian is to
access radio to access books I don't
have anyone to speak to here I'm not
required to be accurate doesn't matter
to me but in the course of three years
of listening and reading I have acquired
a vocabulary of fifty thousand words
that's what link tells me maybe I don't
know all fifty thousand but I know a lot
of words I can read a lot I can listen a
lot and so I have achieved that that's
my goal if I were to live and work in
Russia I work in my accuracy but I
wouldn't go to a school and I wouldn't
study all these rules of grammar that
simply don't make sense to me I'm aware
and I'll occasionally review a grammar
book to remind myself that there are
these rules I pick up the odd thing but
most of it just goes by me and I think
deliberately studying grammar to me is a
thankless job I won't do it so those
that like doing it fine but to suggest
that my Russian is poor because I don't
speak Russian I don't believe that I
believe that people who have studied
grammar deliberately for two or three
years won't be any more accurate than I
am and
far fewer words I can't prove it but
that's what I think so that's with
regard to this discussion the other
thing I think it's very important not to
be too
doctrinaire or dogmatic I do what I like
I observe what other people like I have
seen so many people get frustrated by
traditional grammar based language
instruction in fact I think a lot of the
activities that take place in language
school are useless I think they are
there to amuse the teacher and to some
extent the student so they're amusing
it's something that they like they like
doing it fine do it I would far rather
have the time for myself to study on my
own and that brings me to a reference in
one of the comments that Igor the
Macedonian made and he referred to a
paper and I will also put the URL on my
blog and it's something that someone in
Britain and originally wrote back in
1991 the person's name was something of
my captors name anyway he said that in
order to languages cannot be taught they
can only be learned I've been saying
this I didn't know that someone had said
this 1991 18 years ago and he said that
that the only purpose of a language
teacher is first of all to guide the
language learner to show the language
learner how they can learn on their own
therefore guide number one and two to
answer questions and explain things
about the language when asked those two
things no I think people ask too many
questions
but I do believe that occasionally being
pointed out some things about the
language and quite frankly occasionally
correcting some mistakes as I say not in
the hope that the person will improve
right away but just to help them become
more attentive I think those things have
a place that's what we do it linked we
suggest that people use our forum where
we have native speakers coming on and
helping them again a tutor once a week
talked to the tutor right get it
corrected once a week but mostly just
listen and read now what's interesting
is that this person wrote this report
you can read of my blog 18 years ago now
just think how many things have changed
the Internet the availability of content
the opportunity to interact with people
the to find tutors to find a graded
language material to downloaded onto
your iPod I mean things just exploded
over the last 18 years so what was true
in 1991 is even more true today but by
the same token I don't think we want to
be you have to take some notes here I
forget what I wanted to say you know I
did want to say that most people learn
to be fluent without going to school
historically that's been the case and
most people who are subjected to grammar
based instruction ie today will learn
this tomorrow we learn something else
then I test you on it give you exercises
so you can practice it and then you're
gonna get it right and I'll mark you on
it that kind of instruction mostly
discourages people and it doesn't it
isn't very effective yes we make
mistakes we will inevitably make
mistakes the importance of accuracy
depends on your knees I've said that now
not to Igor who says you know forget any
kind of attempt to learn words or
writing or speaking or output and it's
all useless just listen and read wider
if I were to read five books of toast
though I'd be fluent he says well you
know what I don't like reading if I
don't understand the words and therefore
I read on link where I have access to an
online dictionary so I get an instant
look up but what's more that word goes
into my database because otherwise I'll
forget that I ever even looked it up and
so therefore there's a whole range of
things from flashcards to highlighting
words that you have already looked up
that make it more efficient to do that
reading on the internet which is what I
have done at link for three years and
now I can read more and more things
without being at the computer but it
took me that long to get there also
eager is very strong invited on graded
readers fine I'm agree that it's
important to try to grade material and
again we're going to do a better job
than at link very shortly all material
will be graded against frequency lists
but and of course the big thing is
vocabulary not structure whatever but
the bigger thing rather to me more
important than grading the readers is
interest and I prefer to read things of
interest and so I can read simplified
history perhaps of Russia maybe one or
two not much but when it comes to
literature I want to read the original I
am NOT interested in reading simplified
Tolstoy and I'm not interested in
reading selling stories that's just me
other people different so I think it's
important not to be dogmatic and you
know I'm also on this listserv with
teachers and they're talking about
whether their teachers are kinesthetic
learners are this kind of learner at
that kind of learner and what activities
that you plan for them and I mean they
like doing that there's lots of you like
to go into like going to school to me
it's always the time the teacher is a
guide someone who helps you encourage
you who stimulates you who helps you
find stuff but you have to learn on your
own
which is what the fellow said 18 years
ago that's what I believe to be the case
in the meantime make mistakes
enjoy yourself like Moses mcCormick and
let's not get too serious or pedantic or
dogmatic about all of this and I'm going
to be just within my ten minutes bye for
now